llamas y gases en lacrimógenos es la
imagen de varias ciudades de Pakistán en
el segundo día de protestas tras el
arresto preventivo del ex Primer
Ministro imbran akan acusado de fraude
durante una visita a la capital es la
mavada algo que sus seguidores han
denominado como una caza de brujas
carne dio un mensaje para el pueblo de
Pakistán dijo que debería entregarlo con
sus palabras exactas Dile a la nación
que se impone la ley Marcial o la ley
asin tienen que defender su posición por
el estado de derecho en 2018 campo
declarado culpable por corrupción por
vender supuestos regalos de estado
durante su último año de gobierno por lo
que se le prohibió postularse a las
elecciones de noviembre de 2022 tras lo
que can inició una fuerte campaña contra
los poderes militares del país que ha
culminado en su detención y en una
fuerte crisis apolítica en el país
tenemos instrucciones claras de realizar
protestas pacíficas por parte de
nuestros dirigentes estamos aquí
cíficamente y la policía está lanzando
gases lacrimógenos
desde el inicio de las protestas en
Pakistán se ha suspendido el internet y
ya se han registrado varios muertos y el
gobierno advertido que actuara con más
dureza si las manifestaciones no cesan
un malestar acompañado por una profunda
recesión económica en el país asiático
que está a la espera del rescate del fmi